hey 42 here what's the difference
between the universe and the german
autobahn
the universe has a speed limit okay
logically flawed dad jokes aside the
fact that the speed of light known
simply as
c in scientific notation is the
unbreakable speed limit of the universe
is one of the fundamental laws that
underpins
our understanding of physics but why
exactly
is this the case and can we really not
go any faster
before we get into all of that let's
start with the basics
just how fast is light
this is normally the part of the video
where i proclaim that this is a question
scientists have puzzled over for
millennia but when it comes to the speed
of light
that actually isn't the case because for
much of human history
it was thought that light didn't have
speed
at all that it simply moved
instantaneously
reaching its destination at the precise
moment it left its point of origin
from our smug vantage point here in the
21st century
that might seem pretty stupid how could
anything even something is clearly nippy
as light
move it what would amount to infinite
speed
but when you actually think about it it
isn't all that crazy a conclusion to
come to
after all how the hell do you even begin
to go about demonstrating that light
has a finite speed if you wanted to
prove that
sound doesn't travel at an infinite
speed all you'd have to do is
grab a friend get him to stand as far
away from you as possible
and ask him to vigorously bang drum then
buy him that pint you promised so he
doesn't stop associating with you
the delay between what your eyes see and
what your ears hear
would show you immediately that sound
has a finite speed
and to be honest you don't even need to
set up a crude experiment like this to
prove
this rather obvious fact we see the
finite speed of sound in action
all the time in everyday life the boom
that comes several seconds after a
firework lights up the sky for
example or an echo in a large empty room
even the cool ripple effect you get at
concerts with the crowd bouncing in time
to the music
as sound waves travel towards the back
of the auditorium
try and carry out a similar experiment
with light
however something the great italian
polymath galileo galilei
attempted in 1638 and it's an altogether
different story the experiment galileo
set up
was simple he and one of his assistants
each took a covered lantern to the top
of two distant hills
galileo was to uncover his lantern first
and as soon as his assistant saw the
light he would uncover his own lantern
sending the signal back to galileo using
his pulse or perhaps a water clock
galileo would be able to time
how long it took for light to travel
between the two
hilltops with a small delay introduced
by the reaction time of his assistant
the problem was this small delay
was in fact far far larger
than the actual time it took for the
light from the lanterns
to cover the distance between the
hilltops which would have been
a matter of microseconds the experiment
was a failure
leaving galileo to conclude that either
light did indeed
travel instantaneously or that it moved
at a truly incredible speed
considering the fact that galileo is
quite rightly considered one of the
greatest geniuses in history
it's quite surprising that we had to
wait less than 40 years from the date of
this failed experiment for someone else
to come along and demonstrate for the
first time
that light does indeed have a finite
speed
that man was danish astronomer olay roma
although ironically enough his
breakthrough was based on an unrelated
piece of galileo's own work
in 1598 king philip the third of spain
offered a prize to anyone who could
figure out a way of measuring the
longitude of a ship at sea
that was out of sight of land and
in 1616 galileo did exactly that
he had recently discovered the existence
of one of jupiter's moons
io and his solution to the king's
challenge
rested on using the cyclical timing of
the eclipses of jupiter by
io as a kind of cosmic clock
exactly how that worked isn't relevant
for our purposes
but what is relevant is something
strange ole roma and fellow astronomer
gene pickard not that one
noticed about the period between these
eclipses
which seemed to vary depending on the
time of the year
roma realized the anomaly could be
explained
by the different distances the light was
travelling as the earth
and jupiter move further apart or closer
together
in their respective orbits around the
sun and if
distance was having an impact on the
time it took for the light to arrive
here on earth then it must have been
traveling
at a finite speed roma even had a go at
estimating what that speed might be
based on his observations his answer was
within a creditable
25 of the real figure over the years
since
scores of scientists have had a crack at
calculating a more accurate measurement
for c by the 20th century thanks to
fancy techniques with exotic names like
cavity resonance and
laser interferometry we were able to
calculate
an exact figure for the speed of light
in a vacuum
which is precisely 670 million
616 629
miles per hour that's a smidge over 1
billion kilometers an hour
or for you visual learners out there
fast enough for light to travel 7.5
times around the equator
in a single second yeah no wonder
galileo struggled to pin it down using
his pulse
and a couple of lanterns as a random
aside we now use the speed of light as
the basis for how we measure distance
too
as of 1983 the official definition of a
meter
is the distance travelled by light in a
vacuum
in one 299 million
792 458
of a second give or take but does the
speed of light
really represent the upper limit for the
universe or
is it possible to make something travel
faster
well there are two ways of approaching
that question the first
is practical and the second theoretical
let's start with the practical one
could we with our present technology
make something travel faster than the
speed of light
well the fastest speed ever achieved by
a man-made object
is a record owned by the parker solar
probe
which was landed by nasa in 2018 to
investigate the sun's outer corona
that's the aura of plasma that surrounds
our home star
and it's this you can see as a glowing
halo during a solar eclipse
the parker solar probe is already
rattling on at a fair old lake
but by the year 2025 it will have
reached
its maximum speed 430
thousand miles per hour that's pretty
damn fast
for context a high velocity bullet fired
from a modern rifle
might reach a maximum speed of around 2
500 miles per hour
which is only about 0.6 of the speed
that the parker solar probe will top out
at if superman had a baby with
sonic the hedgehog it wouldn't come
close to the speed after parker solar
probe
yet the probe the bullet
or the mutant superhero offspring for
that matter
still ain't got nothing on light the
parker solar probe
if you're wondering would be traveling
at around 0.0006
of the speed of light or to put it
another way
if light was usain bolt the parker solar
probe
would be an asthmatic geriatric with one
leg whose single foot had been super
glued to the floor
whilst he wasn't looking so no
from a practical standpoint faster than
light travel
is pretty much out of the question for
our species with present technology
anyway
although having said that we have
managed to accelerate
non-man-made objects things we basically
just found lying around the universe
two speeds that are much much faster
than the parker solar probe the large
hadron collider at cern
buried beneath the border between
switzerland and france near geneva
is the world's most powerful particle
accelerator
it's used to explore conditions as they
were in the universe directly after the
big bang
investigates the general weirdness that
is dark matter
and dark energy and it was essential to
proving the existence of the
fabled higgs boson known commonly as the
god particle
using the facilities 27 kilometer
particle accelerator
the largest in the world we've managed
to get
charged particles like electrons to
within a tiny fraction of a percent
of the speed of light but no matter how
hard we try
we've never quite been able to get them
all the way there
and we never will because here's where
we come to the
theoretical part of the answer to our
question and unfortunately
it leaves very little wiggle room for
ftl travel
as an object moves faster it appears to
gain mass
this isn't something we're aware of on a
day-to-day basis because the effect only
really kicks in when we get
very close to the speed of light but we
have to be able to measure it
experimentally in particle accelerators
like the large hadron collider the
closer we get to the speed of light the
more an object's mass increases and the
more energy is required to accelerate
that object any further
before it actually reaches the speed of
light both its mass
and therefore the energy required to
accelerate it further
appear to become infinite put simply the
laws of physics are pretty clear on the
impossibility
of superluminal travel thanks einstein
but wait a second if lightspeed travel
is impossible how come light can do it
ah that's because light is made up of
photons
and like air supermodel after two months
of cucumber juice
and paying a charlatan in a lab coat to
suck her bowels for a plastic tube
photons have no mass meaning
they're exempt from the above
relationship between mass and energy
in fact photons can only travel at the
speed of light
never faster and never slower you may
have heard
that light slows down when it passes
through a medium like water
or glass and that's true but the photons
themselves
never slow down they don't experience
acceleration
or deceleration either the moment they
are brought into existence
they are traveling at the speed of light
so
i guess that about wraps things up for
this video or does it
because hang on a second couldn't i
myself
push light over this apparently
unbreakable speed limit
of our universe just by going for a
light
jog now as you can probably imagine
i'm a pretty nifty mover with a top
speed clocked at a solid 19 miles per
hour
20 if i have trimmed my mustache drag
coefficient can be a
if i were to run at said top speed
whilst holding a shining torch out in
front of me
the light from that torch would be
traveling a smidge over the speed of
light
at precisely c plus 20 miles per hour
thus breaking the unbreakable
speed limit of our universe right
actually wrong whilst the logic seems to
check out
except maybe for the part about my top
speed i'm not as young as i used to be
it turns out that not even light can
break the universe's speed limit
it must always travel at the speed of
light
regardless of who observes it and from
where
which is when you think about it really
bloody weird
according to classical relativity
velocity
is a relative concept if you're standing
on the platform
a passing trade might appear to be
travelling at 100 miles per hour
relative to you but to a passenger on
the train
providing they don't happen to be
looking out of the window the train
would appear to be stationary it's all a
matter
of perspective if you'd like a more
immediate example take a look at the
ground beneath your feet
i'm assuming it's nice and stationary
right now assuming you haven't been
sampling any of those funny coloured
pills again lately
but then again we know that the earth is
actually rotating at around
1 000 miles per hour at the equator
not to mention orbiting the sun at a
healthy 67
000 miles per hour so if you change your
frame of reference
the ground beneath your feet is actually
moving
very very fast indeed an object speed
all depends on the relative speed of the
observer
but light doesn't work that way you
could
in fact attach a torch to the front of a
rocket
travelling at 99 of the speed of light
and the light from that torch
would still be travelling at precisely
the speed of light
no matter where you are observing it
from
so how can this be possible like many of
science's most annoying problems
it was einstein who got to the bottom of
this apparent paradox
his stroke of genius was to realize that
if the speed of light
wasn't changing even as the relative
velocities of the objects around it were
something else must be changing time
put simply the faster an object moves
through space
not only does it appear to gain mass it
also
moves more slowly through time einstein
had come to the startling realization
that time was not constant as had always
been believed
and the foundation for his theory of
special relativity
was laid the logical inference of this
discovery is that light is a constant
that's why it gets to join a special
club with a very limited membership
the universal constant club sometimes
called physical constants
these are measurable components of the
universe
that never change such as gravity
and the game assets in no man's sky the
idea that time slows down for objects
travelling
at speed is for once of a better phrase
trippy is all hell but this relativistic
effect
known as time dilation can actually be
measured in the real world
so it isn't just some theoretical
weirdness that's confined to the pages
of our physics textbooks
in october 1971 physicists
joseph hafele and richard keating
conducted an experiment
where four incredibly accurate cesium
beam
atomic clocks were flown twice around
the world aboard commercial aeroplanes
when they compared the clocks with
others that had spent the duration of
the experiment
chilling on terra firma they found that
the times displayed
were different time on the aeroplanes
had passed
more slowly than it had on the ground
not only that
the amount by which time had slowed
exactly mirrored einstein's predictions
but before you go booking yourself on a
never-ending flight around the world
tour in the hopes of
outliving all of us suckers down here on
earth
at the kind of speeds we're talking
about here the slowing
of time is measured in nanoseconds
still our global gps system
which relies on satellites whizzing
around in orbit at high speed to
triangulate positions here on earth
has to account for time dilation or else
that handy map in your mobile phone
would cease to be usable
at all okay enough of the mind and time
bending stuff
the key takeaway from this video is that
ftl travel
isn't possible because well einstein
says so
alright although now
don't get all excited or anything but
there may just be
a way of sort of kinder achieving
ftl travel without actually accidentally
breaking any fundamental laws of the
universe in the process
a loophole if you will although
confusingly this loophole is actually
a wormhole einstein he really got around
didn't he
predicted the existence of wormholes in
his general theory of relativity
we haven't actually found any yet but if
they do exist
wormholes might essentially represent
shortcuts through space
caused by the warping of space-time
and by traveling through one you could
potentially cover
billions of light-years in mere seconds
without having to move faster than light
at any point
which would prove very valuable if we
ever have ambitions of exploring other
stars
and even other galaxies
okay this one goes a bit weird so to sum
up
light is fast but you can't make
anything else travel that fast
because einstein oh and if you start
thinking too much about special
relativity
the universe as you know it will stop
making any kind of sense
and bits of your brain will probably
start dribbling out of your nose
and on that note thanks for watching
you can now pre-order my brand's new
book stick a flag in it
on amazon link in the description thank
you